a lo largo de mi vida me han dicho en
muchas maneras distintas
me han dicho hiperactiva me han dicho
rara y hasta me han dicho lo k
pero cuando llegué a lope me dijeron de
una manera en la que nunca antes me
habían dicho de la nada estaba con una
amiga platicando y me dijo way intensa
eres
en ese momento fue como a car adictos a
que se refiero porque me dijo eso pero
trata de no darle muchas vueltas en mi
cabeza y seguir con mi día
poco a poco mientras la gente me va
conociendo empezó a surgir una pregunta
clave que siempre era un oye
que tienes porque en la nada me veían en
el antro o en las reuniones prendidas y
ma bailando super ambientada llegan y
era como de que esto ya se le pasaron
las copas y pues no tomo
de la nada estoy aquí en lo que enfría
corriendo y un lugar a otro involucrada
en todas las actividades que se pueden
imaginar y su preocupada en la
computadora y de la nada llegan y es
como de que que tienes tomas de café de
que dejarlo está está haciendo daño
hasta de la nada los que me conocen
saben que yo tiemblo o sea este es mi
pulso normal siempre y entonces la nada
un amigo me ve y me dice que es que no
manches hay tanta intensidad en tu
cuerpo que tú no puede por eso tiembla y
yo vaya no encuentro fallos en su lógica
y hasta una vez estaba con un amigo y me
dijo de que oye a ver si lo compartes
eso que le estás dando para estar como
tú y yo a caray
pero poco a poco pues estas cosas pues
no se ríen no dices ja ja y le sigue
estudia la broma o cambias el tema y no
pasa nada pero lo que sucedió es que
estas frases y estos chistes lo que era
chistoso y ocurrente se empezó a hacer
frecuente y un poco más agresivo se
empezaron a hacer ataques como mi
persona y a mi manera de actuar entonces
eso se transformó en un oye
tranquilízate la realidad organiza su
intensidad
hoy que oye que tyc que tiene s
hasta niños que me decían ningún nombre
va a querer tener una mujer tan intensa
a su lado
y amigos que me decían de que hay que
tyc de que no seas así se más fría hace
más calculadora eres media rarita cuando
te dicen este tipo de cosas pues ya son
ataques a ti pues ya ya te empiezan a
pegar y esa palabra intensa empezó a
resonar en la boca amigos profesores y
hasta niños que me gustaban que me
decían de que eras muy intensa no puedo
contigo
pero empezó a quedar en mérida y poco a
poco me empecé a quedar sola
amigos que yo quería mucho me empezaron
a dejar
perdí relaciones y hasta me despidieron
de trabajos por este mismo tema
eso creo en mí una herida que fue
difícil
fue difícil de afrontar y un día me
hundía en una crisis
una crisis muy difícil en lo que yo
odiaba todo de mí me repugnaba la
persona que era
dudaba de la mujer en la que me había
convertido
no sé si les ha pasado esas noches en
las que estás en la cama y estás en esas
crisis existencial y te preguntas qué
está mal conmigo porque yo lo hice y yo
me pregunte qué está mal conmigo porque
la gente me deja porque me estoy
quedando sola porque me juzgan tanto
porque me critican tanto
porque me siento así porque ya estás
cansada de sentirme así me dolió mucho
esos momentos hasta que entendí que la
parte
la clave era mi perceptibilidad
mis emociones mis sentimientos eso era
mi talón de aquiles
eso era mi demonio mi monstruo que tenía
que dominar que tenía que aplastar
porque soy una persona que se entrega el
1000 por ciento a todas las cosas que
hace que pone el corazón siempre de por
medio y que siente demasiado entonces
como si fuera tan fácil como si yo fuera
una simple máquina yo quería tener un
maldito botón donde yo pudiera apretarlo
clic y olvidarme de mis sentimientos y
de mis emociones
y saben que lo intente tal vez lo
intenten más días de los que me gustaría
aceptar esos días en los que yo trataba
de apretar ese botón y apretar ese botón
para no sentir emociones y sentimientos
hasta que dije de qué se trata esto que
estoy haciendo y les pregunto a ustedes
en qué momentos era una persona intensa
y apasionada se volvió algo malo en qué
momentos era una persona que demuestra
sentimientos y emociones debió haber
sido algo que se juzga que se rechaza
que se critica nos gritan vulnerables
débiles exagerados a todas aquellas
personas que tenemos el valor de
demostrar nuestros sentimientos y es que
la sociedad no le gusta la gente intensa
los agarre los excluye los lleva lejos
para que se sientan mal y poco a poco
los va aplastando hasta que logra
pagarlos
todo esto a mí me afectó mucho y después
de estas conclusiones
yo dije creo que el principal problema
fue en el momento que nosotros leímos
una connotación negativa a la palabra
intensidad por eso me di a la tarea de
investigar en la rae cuál era la
verdadera definición de intenso o
intensa y dice que es muy vehemente o
vivo y después aquí encontré una palabra
muy chistosa de mente y la busqué y se
se aplica a los fenómenos o efectos que
se comportan con mucha intensidad fuerza
energía y después de leer eso fue como
soy un fenómeno ahora me salió peor
déjenme decirles algo la humanidad son
sentimientos y sin sentimientos no somos
humanidad pero les tengo una mala
noticia se nos está olvidando cómo
sentir en qué momento quisimos dejar de
lado las emociones y todo eso que le da
fuerza y color y magia a nuestra vida en
qué momento quisimos dejar de lado esas
emociones esos colores invisibles que
pintan nuestro día a día
porque dejamos de hacer esto
porque somos así
y en este momento yo estaba pensando
pues bueno es que porque llegamos a esto
porque son porque estamos cayendo en
este tipo de cosas y entonces entendí
que parte de esto era porque estábamos
subiendo
por un factor principal por el miedo el
miedo a sentir el miedo involucrarnos a
exponernos a que nos lastimen ese miedo
es lo que nos frena la falta de
involucramiento emocional es el factor
que nos frena a tomar acción y ayudar a
otros
y las marcas en las empresas lo saben
porque aunque nosotros queramos negar
nuestros sentimientos y nuestras
emociones no podemos dejar nuestra
naturaleza entonces buscamos fuera lo
que tenemos dentro y lo buscamos en
bebidas en comida en tecnología drogas
alcohol pero ya nos hemos desactivado
tanto que cada vez estamos detonantes
más y más y más fuertes para podernos
sentir algo
y ellos lo saben ellos saben que la
clave está en lo emocional en el momento
que activo a ti te hacen sentir algo ya
te traen aquí donde ellos quieren y por
eso vemos titulares de experiencia
extrasensorial emociones al límite
desbordante experimenta algo único pero
ya después de ver yo todo esto y llegar
a estas conclusiones dije ok necesito
ver cuáles son los problemas y cómo esto
está afectando nuestro día a día en
nuestras vidas
y entonces encontré que hay más de 300
millones de personas que sufren de
depresión una depresión que está ahogada
en sentimientos que está en sentimientos
reprimidos que no se saben manejar que
no se saben entender y que por ende no
se quieren a sí mismos y no pueden
querer a otros una depresión que si no
se trata que si no se hace algo lleva a
un suicidio y ahí encontré cifras muy
impactantes
en el mundo hay una muerte cada 40
segundos y en méxico hay una muerte cada
1.30 segundos y muchas de las causas de
esto es el factor emocional y hasta en
el ámbito de las parejas me metí a
investigar bien y vi que los divorcios
ha subido un 136 por ciento en los
últimos 15 años y porque vuelvo a lo
mismo
el miedo tenemos miedo de conocer a
nuestra pareja tenemos miedo de abrirnos
a ellas porque abrirnos a esa persona
implica enseñarle nuestras heridas
enseñarle quien realmente somos y por
ende exponer nuestro pasado y nadie
quiere hacer eso porque ese es el camino
difícil entonces lo fácil me bloqueó no
lo hago agarramos el corazón y lo
guardamos en un cajón por eso ahorita
las relaciones son tan frágiles y tan
superficiales porque ya no ponemos el
corazón de por medio cambiamos de pareja
tan fácil como si fuéramos que iu a las
personas que si son que demuestran y que
quieren con el corazón dicen de que hay
que empalagoso
o hay que tyc no seas así y de que cada
quien sus propios intereses y ya no cada
quien como por su lado y listo y no
pero ya vimos toda la parte mala
entonces y yo evidentemente sabía que el
mundo no era color de rosa y quería
entender primero esta parte pero también
quería saber si estaba sola o no dije
debe de haber más personas que sean como
yo más personas que sean intensas que
tengan todos estos sentimientos y estas
emociones y hayan hecho algo con su vida
con ello y si evidentemente encontré
estos ejemplos que estoy segura que
ustedes van a identificar esta mujer
madre teresa de calcuta una mujer
sumamente intensa que tomó su corazón
todas sus emociones y sus sentimientos y
las entregó a un amor humilde y sencillo
a todos los pobres y enfermos o como
estas niñas que son unas intensas de lo
peor que dejan el corazón en la cancha y
que están dispuestos a desafiar y a
romper paradigmas y hacer nuevos récords
cómo llegar a una final o hasta estos
dos hombres
martin luther king un nombre que tomó
toda su intensidad y todos sus
sentimientos y las tradujo en un sueño
eso que le quebraba el corazón eso que
le dolía de su gente lo tradujo en un
sueño al que le dedicó
porque tener justicia e igualdad para su
gente o como charles chaplin que decía
que hay veces que pensamos mucho y
sentimos muy poco y él utilizó toda esa
energía todos esos sentimientos todas
las emociones y hacía reír a la gente
nos hacía feliz nos trataba de que
disfrutaran un poquito más de sus días
ya después de ver yo a todos ellos me
sentí más en paz pero sin embargo no
estaba feliz porque porque aún no me
entendía aún no me quería
y entonces yo entendí que tenía que
hacer de aquello que me destruía lo que
me construía y para eso era necesario
aceptar quién era yo y sentirme
orgullosa de lo que era
entonces si esa mujer intensa quererme a
mí misma entonces ustedes deben de tomar
eso que les hace únicos y abrazarlo
porque en el momento que ustedes toman
eso y se aceptan se entienden quiénes
son y se quieren ahora se llevan a ser
feliz es fácil porque entonces ya ya
pueden construir un camino ya pueden
saber a dónde van
y ahora si pueden trascender
pero a ver no se me confundan yo no les
vine a decir aquí que entonces hay que
vivir al máximo hoy hay que sentir por
sentir y yo lo oí no
lo que yo les viene a decir el día de
hoy es que una gran intensidad conlleva
una gran responsabilidad y si tal vez
esto les suena un poquito parecido a la
frase que le dijo el tío ven a peter
parker pero lo que yo les quiero decir
con esta frase es que todos esos
sentimientos todas esas emociones que
ustedes tienen no las dejen solamente
ahí tomen las canalicen las del es un
sentido un fin del es un proyecto
trasciendan con ellos y así van a ser
felices nos avergüencen de esos
sentimientos o de esas emociones están
ahí por alguna razón porque en ellos
está el secreto y la clave de su misión
en la vida con aquello que les quiebra y
les acelera el corazón
la sensibilidad no es vulnerabilidad
somos más fuertes los que sentimos más
quiero decirles algo que yo creo
firmemente y que espero que ustedes
también lo crean su corazón puede
cambiar el mundo
su inteligencia puede dirigirlos a la
verdadera felicidad que está siempre en
ayudar a los demás
yo antes
era una persona que me tumbaba cada vez
que utilizaban la palabra intensa hacia
mí me dolía muchísimo me hacía odiarme y
me frenada
pero ahora es mi auténtica descripción
ojalá ustedes también puedan ser unos
intensos para ser felices
[Aplausos]